so this new tax announcement the
Conservatives announced it last week you
actually announced in august what's new
about it i think what's new about this
debate on tax cuts is not who's
promising tax cuts lots of people are
doing that left right and center now i
mean david cameron you know promise the
moon on a stick last week lots of
possible money for the NHS and tax cuts
for everybody but didn't spell out who
pay what we are saying is in our first
installment our first step towards this
magic goal of no one paying income tax
on the first twelve and a half thousand
pounds they earn we will fund for it fed
and your big sell on this going into the
election after you know a tough time
politically in terms of the pain you've
taken in the polls will be that you
delivered more or less the manifesto
commitment on on the income tax
allowance already more actually well the
less i mean it's very important to
remember this because I mean obviously
I'm constantly all you didn't do you
didn't deliver on one of your manifesto
commitments actually on our front page
I'm sure you have a well-thumbed copy an
idea that's all their crap manifest on
your bedside table due to negative wells
on lucazec that's a confession and
you'll see that on the front page we
said that we would raise the point at
which people start paying contact from
where we found it which is what 6400 to
10,000 and by the way what's so
interesting to taos ski the
conservatives could a plagiarizing idea
on this was it in all of the
negotiations I've done the last four
years I had to fight tooth and nail
that's against David Cameron George
Osborne who kept saying to me privately
oh this is your tax cut and if you want
this Nick you're gonna have to do this
that Neil said it was your texts are you
absolutely okay yes of course
conservatives say that 12 and a half
thousand pounds allowance is your tax
cut all the pages all the budget
negotiations are the last several years
getting it up to ten thousand ten a half
thousand with something I had to do I
had to press very hard how much money
did the vit rise raise well the vit
Reiter arrays roughly similar exactly
the same amount so you've taken from
people's wallets and giving it back in
their pay packets but you don't want to
take the hit for the vit rise but you do
want the electoral game very good be
very open I've been very open about the
fact actually unlike the Conservatives
what we can't pretend any longer is that
you can balance the books by only
gouging out more and more money from
public spending alone that you can only
ask the the working-age poor to to pay
for the mistakes the boss that tax of
course plays a role in that now with the
v8 with the video with the ATM
highly cynical move to raise really at
the beginning and give away exactly the
same amount at the end of the Parliament
it's just it's just recycling money from
the same that is not that is absolute
not the case in fact if you look at the
distribution of analyses of what we've
done over the last several budgets we've
done it very fairly even with the VA t
change okay well let's talk about
political errors and one of your most
senior backbenchers a former minister
Jeremy Browne has described even a very
slogan of this conference is kind of
mitigating other parties stronger
economy than labor fairer than the
Tories you're a party of mitigation not
a party of majority Jeremy is talking
completely you know in the back of his
head it doesn't read the slogan it's all
about delivering opportunity for
everyone is more liberal than
opportunity that is what we're about how
do you deliver that well you have to
deliver that by getting this balance
right but in a strong economy and a fair
society so there I say Jeremy by may be
just only read the first bit of the
slogan and emitted actually the whole
point of it which is that we want
opportunity for every well there's a
game of changing the country there's
also a game of politics if I tell you
now I could have told you in 2010 where
you'd be in the polls and if that would
remain at seven percent you still would
have said yes ten times over hundred
times a thousand times over yes yeah
I'll tell you why look the little doubt
for a political party not a think tank
we're not a sort of you know discussion
group we want to change this country for
the better you can't change this country
for the better unless you're prepared to
endure the brickbats and all the insults
and all the kind of all that kind of
stuff and yes and a big get your hands
dirty why have you personally changed
your position on airport expansion in
the southeast no I haven't I remember
I've always been very hostile to plans
for the expansion of Heathrow for all
the reasons you'll be familiar with just
where it's located I care about making
sure that we remain the green
sustainable economy the question then is
a rather technical one is can you do
that given those very significant
advances now in engine technology and
making sure that in making aeroplanes
lighter and more fuel efficient and less
less polluting can you can you operate
within the strict parameters of our
climate change commitments but at the
same time also somewhere and make sure
that air capacity is reformed and if
necessary expand in order to make sure
that our economy continues to be an open
one and
connected to the rest of the world
that's the that's the circle we're
trying to square will you be encouraging
the Prime Minister to take part in TV
debates yes of course he should he said
I was I think it's foot-dragging from
the Conservatives it's just getting a
bit boring now I mean let's get on with
it we had it we had the TV debates last
time people enjoyed them you know I
think they liven up the whole thing
they're actually quite good fun I do
honestly I don't think the toys just you
know either didn't come clean if they
want to run scared then they should come
clean and say they don't want to do them
but not this endless kind of ducking and
weaving I think people want the TV
debates and and and the more people can
see how the leaders measure up against
each other the better